hello frogs how's everybody
hope you're doing fine today we're gonna
have a great day but not what you
expected probably first I want to remind
everyone we have a a conference in
Lusaka Zambia okay you can sign up for
it at rational school calm and it'll be
the adventure of your life time so beg
borrow and steal whatever make it -
lusaka okay you want an exotic vacation
this is a good time to have one okay the
other thing I want to remind people we
uploaded a book the other day it's a
free book you can download it anytime
you want it set rope hypothesis calm you
go to book books there and you can
download it okay and it gives you an
introduction to the rope model of light
the rope hypothesis okay and one of the
things we're looking for is for people
to email us if they have a second
language if they know if they have
another mother tongue like in my case I
have two mother tongues well someone
else might be able to good make a good
translation into some other language and
if they do well we would really
appreciate you know the translation of
the rope hypothesis into another
language and yeah you can email us at
toll kakaako at hotmail let me put that
up there again you can email us here at
hotmail.com
okay and if you are interested in
translating book okay so what's the deal
today I was going to talk about Google
Aristotle and Euclid I was gonna
continue with the subject of infinity
and I'm gonna have have to postpone that
until Wednesday
I had a series of questions come oh come
up and I want to address those questions
today because they go to the heart of
what science is what physics is about
and also what the rope model is about so
you know these are like the foundations
and so I think the questions are
important that's one issue the other
issue is that you know this these
comments they represent what the
majority of people believe or think out
there and that's another reason we need
to address these issues ok ok so let's
get started here's the first comment ok
fella says his bills mine right
scientific process does not allow for
new experimentation or observations he
unfortunately refuses to acknowledge the
experimental physicists who do all the
hard work poor souls that leads to those
observations that allows him to draw
conclusions Bill's version of science
assumes we already have all available
evidence that is that is why he puts
experimentation investigation into his
religious basket ok mighty words ok how
do we address that ok let's let's look
at this deserves an answer yeah yeah and
here we have John Baez and his crackpot
index which he applies to all distance
and the first one is that it doesn't
address you know there's no provision
for hard work in science today
he says 10 points for beginning in the
description of your theory by saying how
long you have been working on it 10 more
for emphasizing that you worked on on
your own ok so hard work doesn't cut it
you know if you have an irrational
theory we don't care how much hard work
you put behind it and you know it's
still irrational so hard work doesn't
cut it but let's address some of those
other issues there and in rational
there is no provision for
experimentation or gawking some kind
observation we caught gawking okay if
you got you're not a scientist so
observation is not part of science okay
a lot of people I have trouble with that
to say well how do you know what to
explain if you haven't observed it well
again you know I keep giving the
examples and some people simply don't
get it Stephen Hawking never observed a
black hole that doesn't mean he cannot
theorize about it and I'm sure Einstein
never observed spacetime okay especially
with this two eyes so you don't need to
observe anything to be able to theorize
about it they're not related okay but
you can see that there's no provision
for experiments either in there where do
you see a provision for experiments
that's the reason you know experimental
and observations and all this stuff
investigation that doesn't have anything
to do with science in science you got
explained because that's what science is
science is a body of rational
explanations okay so let's go with the
second issue raised by the same
gentleman but again he represents quite
a bit of people out there that's why I
like to put these comments up there
because I want to address them I want to
make sure they don't go flying by and
you get blindsided to them no I'd like
to address these things his version mine
right of science is very similar to how
religion itself explains the universe
I'm a religious fanatic I'm a
religionist
good okay there is no room for retesting
the assumption because as he says it is
not science
yes retesting whatever is not part of
science we don't read tests we don't
verify you know none of that we don't
prove okay you have to believe them just
like religion uh-huh
but you believe my mechanism is your
religion true bill does that allow you
to question his assumptions false
okay so let's let's put that in the
proper perspective so that we're on the
same page okay we'll make sure we all
understand what we're proposing okay in
science the crowd takes an assumption at
face value in order to understand the
theory found it upon it okay so someone
makes an assumption and assumption you
say okay we can see you we concede your
assumption okay
now explain the theory now you have to
base your theory on that assumption so
so we concede the assumption you can
talk about angels if you want we just
want to listen to what you have going
through your mind then we're gonna go
further and here you can see the
reporters can and should question the
assumptions at the end of the talk okay
if the assumptions are shown to be
irrational the theory falls outside of
science okay so the issue here is that
not that we don't allow people to
question okay the issue is that you know
we we use the assumptions in order for
you to understand the theory the
mechanism in case of physics okay you
want to understand the cause what causes
gravity what is the mechanism underlying
magnetism and so we begin with an
assumption the assumption includes as we
just shown a second ago here let's see
if I can find it again put it give me a
second here I here it is that's the
Assumption hypothesis is the synonym of
assumptions it presents the objects the
definitions and the initial scene okay
when you question them yeah you can
question them in fact afterwards you let
the guy give the presentation then you
say look you know you we got a problem
with your assumptions no problem there
you can question the assumptions what
you can't do is is believe in them so
he's wrong about that we don't believe
in assumptions we take them at face
value to understand the theory founded
on it upon okay
mathematical physics doesn't exactly in
reverse they don't know how you to
question the assumptions before or after
never you're not allowed to here you
have a case in point okay
yeah biases crackpot index again ten
points for each claim that quantum
mechanics is fundamentally misguided you
can't question quantum mechanics it's a
done deal okay
ten points each claim for claim that
special or general relativity are
fundamentally misguided so you can't
question those assumptions anymore you
know they were theories they became
proof and now they're used as
assumptions you can't question the
Assumption anymore before or after the
presentation and no that's not what
science is in science we do we are in
fact we're we're required to question
the assumptions if we have a problem
with them okay so yeah we do question
the assumptions okay and you know bias
says you should not question the
assumptions of both quantum mechanics
and general relativity and here you have
I show this the other day you have a
couple of bozos mister bore the video
Susskind and richard fineman and they
tell you we don't understand quantum
mechanics
okay essentially I'll just read the last
one for from fine then I think I can
safely say that nobody understands
quantum mechanics do not keep asking
yourself if you can possibly avoid it
but how can it be like that
nobody knows how it can be like that the
more you see how strange the nature
behaves the harder it is to make a model
that explained how even the simplest
phenomena actually were so theoretical
physics has given up on that okay and
here's bias again just in case in this
crackpot in there she said ten points
for arguing that while a current
well-established theory meaning quantum
and you know and general relativity
predicts phenomena correctly it doesn't
explain why they occur or fails to
provide a
mechanism in other words mathematical
physics so-called science which this
fellow apparently defense okay doesn't
explain any mechanism there is no
mechanism in all of mathematical physics
in all of so-called science
big word for all easy so there are no
scientists out there scientists is not a
guy who develops gadgets that's
technology scientists is that a guy who
does equations that's a mathematician
that's a language that's like saying you
know Chinese this guy knows mathematics
of a symbol a language of symbols of
hieroglyphics that he can establish
relations with that so what what does
that have to do with science science I
need to explain how gravity works that's
what I need to to be able to explain
that mechanism and none of these guys
can make money they tell you right in
your face we don't understand how the
universe works we we don't pay attention
to mechanisms so we do not explain or as
professor emeritus Donald was the name
Semenuk
what is it
Lock Haven University of Pennsylvania
he says science doesn't explain science
describes why because only Matt the only
thing math can do is describe math has
no power to explain anything you cannot
explain gravity you can access brain
magnetism the cause the the the
mechanism all you can do is describe it
mathematically but you cannot explain it
and that's why mathematics has turned
into mathematical physics and
mathematical physics is all descriptions
there is no explanation no rational
explanation and when you confront these
people they say well you we know we know
we can't explain so what that's not
science science is the equation the
description that's the problem okay so
here we have another comment from this
individual says can't eat a scientific
thought process is a continuous process
of learning
learning you mean like memorizing is is
that what it is we go to school and they
say the teacher tells you read from page
45 to 50 because they're going to test
you on Friday
and so you read it you memorize it you
get an a on the test you forget at T
days later because you passed the test
is that the process of science is that
what learning means but then you get
into the what he continues era teaches
because in science we can't prove well
thank God he said that you know yeah
in science we can't prove but then he
says until we can't falsify the
hypothesis falsify that sounds like
proof you know you either prove or
falsify right and if you can't falsify I
guess you proved right what is the Pope
Arian falsifiability where he gets these
terms that he doesn't understand a
statement is falsifiable if some
observation might show it to be false
okay false that's an opinion that's a
belief is guide to false or true is
space-time false or true is a particle
at two places at once true or false I
mean you know how are you gonna falsify
that and for example all swans are white
is falsifiable safai of gold policy
viable because here is a Black Swan
shows it to be false yeah that statement
the statement right so that's not a
theory okay that's that's just an
assumption okay and so what you don't
you're not really falsifying the
Assumption you're you're saying that it
is irrational
it's an incorrect statement now you want
to call that false of falsifiability
fine but that's got nothing to do with
with what this means individual sayings
falsifying the hypothesis he's thinking
of the theory the the he's saying that
he for him the hypothesis and atheria
are synonyms a hypothesis is just a
theory that
not been tested so well that's in
general the notion all these people have
so let's go with falsify first okay here
here it is how do you falsify this here
you have Stephen Hawking he says that
there are such things as black holes
black holes are zero dimensional there's
no like he says there's zero size and
how do you falsify that how you falsify
a zero size object well what are you
supposed to do go out there and bring it
in you know how you're gonna drag it in
if it's just zero size object and that's
what he says Chandrasekhar
prove and got a Nobel Prize for for
proving that starts can collapse beyond
their structure and how do you falsify
Niels Bohr's this simple to say that a
particle can be at two places at once
how do you falsify that I mean you run a
test where the particle is supposed to
be at two places at once prove that I
mean you know what these guys have done
is simply infer this is their conclusion
based on the particle hypothesis and
they say well the only we can explain
with particles is that the particle is
at two places at once that's a different
story than saying that you know that you
have proven the existence that of
particles first and that a particle can
be at two places at once and then so
what you need to go is to move this word
hypothesis okay that this fella is using
again he thinks it's a theory and here
you have different references different
ideas different notions you'll find on
the Internet about what the hypothesis
is and no one has figured it out in the
last 10,000 years no one knows what that
word means and here you see objectives
this is one common mistake the purpose
or hypothesis upon which the project is
based
so here the this person thinks it's a
purpose another person thinks it's a
question or statement in statement form
for example Sargassum ensure we'll have
fewer organisms than Sargassum or
offshore okay just a statement that you
want to prove or or something that again
a purpose may be something you want to
do then you have another one a tentative
guess or hunt in other words a
prediction
that what hypothesis is a prediction I
mean if it's a prediction how can it be
a question or a purpose and here you
have another one it says something taken
to be true for the purposes of argument
or investigation and assumption is an
assumption the same thing as a
prediction there's a tentative guess as
a question as a something you want to
investigate is that what an assumption
is a hypothesis is an explanation with
some evidence and testing behind it so
is an assumption the same thing as an
explanation and then we have another one
any physical theory is always
provisional in the sense that is only a
hypothesis so a theory is a hypothesis
so and then the last two a tentative
theory about the natural world or data
analysis so you get all these notions of
what a hypothesis is none of these
people have ever figured out no
hypothesis is the set of assumptions
that you have to make in order to
understand the theory and the way we do
it in science and genuine science you
present the objects that's part of the
hypothesis you have the set of
definitions that's part of the
hypothesis and then you have the initial
scene or the first frames of the film
you know the detective goes to the crime
scene he's he's a body on the floor with
a knife on the back first he describes
the scene okay and so that's the
hypothesis that's the starting point of
his theory and if you don't understand
what a knife is or or what a body is
well then he presents those edges
exhibit one exhibit two the objects and
then he's got the definitions you don't
know what a crime what the word crime
means what stabbing means okay so he
defines it that's the start that's the
hypothesis not all this nonsense that
these people have come up with which is
a tentative theory a tentative
explanation a prediction an assumption
and all this mixed together and
everything is a hypothesis according to
these people yeah so here's a comment
that I found in the dictionary which I
kind of liked okay about what hypothesis
is it all comes down to belief in
mathematical physics in so-called
science hypothesis a proposition that
attempts to explain a set of facts a
scientific law is a hypothesis that is
assumed to be universally true true true
to whom I mean it's got a trophy
hypothesis how many people should be
count four billion is that good enough
how about six billion or should be way
to all humanity believes in it when does
it you know become more when does it
become true so so this word true is just
belief it's just an opinion and that's
that where it stops it continues in law
has good predictive power predictive you
don't do predictions in science that's
astrology new hypothesis is inconsistent
with well-established laws well
established by whom I mean by the
Vatican or was it by the mullahs in Iraq
who established these laws so-called
laws are generally rejected yeah they
reject anything that goes against
quantum mechanics and general relativity
because those are established laws by
whom by a group of monks that are int
Ambridge and harbor that's all it is
so they've established these laws and
now you got to abide by these laws right
a theory is a set of statements
including laws and hypothesis that
explains I thought they just said that
they couldn't explain so what they don't
do hypothesis in in general Rodes in
what is it mathematical physics because
they they don't explain they claim they
don't explain they say descriptions is
what science and math physics are about
so obviously they're not explaining so I
don't know why they put the word explain
in there explains a group of
observations or phenomena broad
acceptance acceptance acceptance by home
who is accepting does that mean it's an
opinion it's a it's whoever believes is
is that what this is all about belief
broad acceptance of a theory comes one
and has been tested repeatedly on new
data and been used to to make accurate
predictions again what those predictions
have to do with explanation
and you know we're talking about an
accepted theory what's that got to do
with with an expletive prediction a
prediction is a description anything you
proceed you you predict is always a
description you say my horses won't
gonna win number five and your horse
gets there first so you made a correct
prediction what did you explain all you
did was describe the moon's gonna cause
an eclipse tomorrow two o'clock what did
you explain all you did was describe but
if you can explain now you're talking
about the past
now you're drawing on your experience
you already had
you're not predicting you're looking
backwards that frontwards you're you're
thinking of something that you've
already you already have experience with
and that's why you can explain it
explanations only have to do with the
past and that's all that science has to
do with predictions has nothing to do
with that so you know again all these
have contradictions in in their
statements and your notions okay so
broad exceptional theory comes when it
has been tested repeatedly Allah all the
way to predictions all the hypotheses of
relativity have now achieved the
authority of scientific laws so you got
to believe it or or kill yourself you
have to accept this CD you have
authority now you have to bow down to
Authority again belief some people
believe this nonsense that there's a
four-dimensional space-time within which
we live right and they say well you're
not supposed to take any of that
literally we we don't we can't explain
it but here's the here's the equation I
don't care about your stupid equation I
want to know how this universe works for
this I need to know why the earth
doesn't fly out of the Sun out of the
solar system
I want to know why the moon that goes
around the earth doesn't fly out of the
solar system that's what we need to
understand the mechanism these people
are saying that space is warped
space-time is warped that means time is
warped and time is holding the earth
from running out of the solar system
that's what they're telling you
and so they say well that's just an
analogy well an analogy for what what
was the point of the analogy of you're
saying that time is worn in time as a
concept what do you mean time is work
what does that mean and and yeah they
drive it to you through authoritative a
theory become so completely accepted by
whom by Harvard in Cambridge it stops
being referred to as a theory now it's a
fact a proof of whatever knowledge okay
so yeah space-time is now that we can't
criticize that anymore it's been proven
according to these people okay there's
no chance to to challenge it and it's
interesting I looked up where the here
here the religions of the world okay
and you can see that most people believe
in God right
some call Allah God whatever doesn't
matter they believe in a single day D up
there right and then you got number
three you got what is 1.1 billion people
are apparently atheists agnostics a
little bit of everything there they are
non-believers okay are they now they
believe in other Nazis worse nonsense
they were believed in mathematical
physics most of those okay so you got it
you got a situation where you know the
mathematical physics laughs at the other
guy says you believe in God are you
kidding me you show me what God is prove
to me that God exists and the other guy
turns around says what is this
four-dimensional space-time that you
cannot even imagine or how is a particle
at two places at once
and this guy is what's he going to say
how does it you got to explain that what
explanation does that possibly have so
is are those so-called non religious
folk any better than the so-called
religious now they're all religious
they're all religious because they're
all do rational folk you know you're
talking about more than 99% of humanity
of irrational completely irrational
because one guy believes in God and
spirits and miracles the other guy
even worse stuff he believes in
space-time that you can travel backwards
and kill your grandfather forward and
kill your grandson you know and what
black holes that are zero that meant you
know what is this nonsense
what does that have to do with
rationality and with science so yeah all
these people are religious there is no
difference between them
and people should keep those things in
mind when they're looking at you know if
you're if you're into science you should
keep these things in your mind at the
back of your mind okay here's another
comment by this gentleman and again says
definitions are important and the first
thing you find you know geometry they
never define point or line they say
they're undefined terms
nobody has ever defined the word energy
we don't have a definition for the word
mass nobody knows what mass is it's not
the quantity of matter by the way so you
have this in the back of your hand
that's what you learned in high school
that's been overthrown okay so you
better look at that up and when you try
to define terms like you know critical
ones that make or break any theory in
physics like the word object you can't
do physics without an object okay and
you try to define those terms very
rigorously people start trembling
because it destroys their religion and
so they dismiss it as semantics
so yeah definitions are important except
in so-called mathematical physics except
in science science as equal to
mathematical physics in in genuine
science they are important yeah
and so I define a there he says object
that which has shape exactly and then he
says well a shape is a two-dimensional
object and form is a three-dimensional
object that's an ordinary speech not in
science in science we only have black or
white okay and here let's see I've got a
little little thing here to compare it
against okay so that you can see what
I'm referring to in physics there is no
great physics there is only black and
white sorry we're all racist in physics
okay it's only black or white you got to
make it
very clear very crisp okay a word
alludes to a concept or to an object
there's no other type of word in the
entire dictionary it either alludes to
that which has shape or to that which
doesn't okay if it doesn't it's a
concept very simple you say these love
love is a concept why because you can't
draw love you can't draw intelligence
you can't draw energy you can't draw
force field
tying none of those words you can make a
drawing you cannot sketch it you cannot
make a picture of it that's where their
concepts in general that's that's a good
rule of thumb object if table you can
draw you know you can draw what is it
rock you can draw a tree you can draw
any of those things those are objects so
if you can't tell the difference between
an object and a concept you need to see
a psychiatrist
okay in ordinary speech shape is not
equal to form but in physics shape and
form are synonyms okay so there is no
difference between shape and form
because we need to define the word
crisply for the purposes of of physics
and you know and none of these other
things criteria can be used in physics
for the definition of the word object
you cannot use see touch which is the
addiction area the definition you'll
find in many dictionaries you cannot use
mass volume motion that is made of
something because Murie ology or
temporal parts it can't be the subject
of a sentence that's not you can talk
about motion motion is not an object you
talking about orbit orbit is not orbit
is a verb for the purposes of physics
okay so you can't use any word that in
ordinary speech used as a subject of the
sentence of a sentence or as a noun
those don't automatically go into
physics as objects okay not that which
has color or not that which exists and
not which that that which is 3d the only
only universal of objects every object
has is shape and so we don't distinguish
between shape and form whether it's 2d
or 3d that's a second matter
we haven't gotten to that far because
the first word we have to define in
physics is the word object so we can't
go and say well how many dimensions does
it have we haven't word reach the word I
mentioned yet we haven't defined the
word you dimension okay so no the only
property or attribute whatever that all
objects have is shape that you can put
your money on okay and that's the
definition for physics and of course
this destroys a lot of religions just
just ponder it for a second you know God
does he have shape or not if God doesn't
have shape is a concept it's a concept
and if God has shape then God's an
object and so now we have a little bit
of problem because now the guy has to
decide and of course a lot of religious
people hate that type of predicament
because they can't they can't answer
that and a lot of them will say stuff
like well you know if I knew what God
was you wouldn't be so great and to get
around it anyway they can with with a
little bit of word wizardry right but no
God either has shape or God does and if
God doesn't have shave God is a concept
and you're praying to a concept
hopefully the concept is listening got
ears you know ah here's another comment
this young man this puts it in a lot of
perspective he says looking forward to
the time when we skipped out history
lessons and delve into the details of
the Rope hypothesis oh my god well it
shows that this person has a very short
attention man or some mental problem I
don't know and all I can do is but this
explains a lot about him you know maybe
he suffers from one of these ailments
maybe he's got attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder ADHD or a short
attention span right superficial mind or
Twitter mentality you know when liners
that's all you can handle
maybe he's enough spare your Scout
autism or something you know or the
onset of Alzheimer's I mean maybe that's
why you can't keep up yeah you need to
have history lessons enough to put
everything in the right context you need
to know where the
word infinity or infinity came from
which we're gonna get to in a minute
here you know who came up with these
idiotic words I mean there is no such
thing as infinity as applied to physics
you can't say whether the universe is
infinite or finite okay
these are irrational statements
irrational questions
you cannot say if the universe is
infinite is the universe
you know finite you know if universe is
a concept they can't be finite or
infinite okay and people have to you
know get into that habit of the language
the language is absolutely crucial here
okay
and in fact that's the question that he
came up with next
he says for anyone interested learning
about the different types of infinity as
defined by mathematics and he gives a
reference there so you go to the
reference and you find this girl who's
got a very sexy voice so if you're into
sex hey you may want to visit that site
but she's a dumb blonde okay forget it
it's far as physics is concerned let me
tell you why I she goes in there and she
does this she puts hilbert space and she
talks about the infinity of dimensions I
call it the infinity of dementia okay
because she puts all these little arrows
she says those are dimensions and
they're infinite dimensions and you know
that mention has only two properties as
we will explain in the future
lecture and that's orthogonal T and
direction and none of these are
orthogonal in other words all those have
less than 90 degree angles okay and so
they can't be infinite dimensions
because none of those are dimensions and
again what happens is all these people
confuse number lines for dimensions they
think that they call number lines
dimensions vectors and coordinates and
so people say oh they're talking about
they mention your four-dimensional
space-time no it's four numbered lined
space-time space-time is that a
dimensional thing it's a number line
thing they're telling you how many times
how many number lines you need to locate
a point
any other problem with number line since
they don't have direction number nine
has no direction it's not a property of
number line just magnitude that's all
the number line has and so she ends up
putting all these in different
directions when number lines don't have
direction and she's called some
dimension Co multi-dimensional you know
infinite dimensions just nonsense words
she never even pondered the issue when
she when she you know studied if you
call that say she just memorized
whatever they gave her okay and yeah
addressing let's address this issue and
let's put it back up here again he says
let me put this other one here as well
he says he's talking about infinity and
he says one application of infinity we
don't know whether the universe
everything that contains all matter is
infinite or whether it has boundaries
well yeah we start out by saying that
there is no gray and everything's black
and white either it's an object or a
concept and in the case of the universe
universe is a concept concept the the
concept universe stands for space and
matter
the concept universe has two it's a
relation between space and matter that's
what it is and the first thing you got
to determine is whether you're talking
about matter you turn about space so the
question is whether space is a physical
object a medium a box container I don't
know how else to put that is a body of
water I mean would is space if space is
an object we can talk about the object
being finite in fact it had better be
finite if it's an object because that's
the definition of the word object that
which has shape something that is
infinite is is not an object because you
you can't figure is its shape it's
infinite what is it is it growing as you
try to see it I mean you have to
conceptualize it on the board so anyone
who believes that space is a physical
object has to make a picture of space on
the board
and identify the entity the medium
whatever that encapsulates space okay
what what encapsulated space thought I
mean water what do we have out there
another dimension is that what
encapsulate space so this is this is a
conceptual issue we don't need to send
the rocket out there to the edge of
space to find out what's out there no
this is a conceptual issue just draw it
on the board see but we want to see
what's in your mind if you say space is
a physical object and the stars and the
atoms and everything are within this
this container then draw the container
and show me what's outside the container
and you can't say well that's
unscientific because we have no way of
proving or demonstrating what's out
there it's a conceptual issue you just
have to tell me what you're going to
call that call it X what is X is it is
it about what contains X and then what
contains that other thing that contains
X and so on down the line and that's why
it's an unending story you can never say
that space is a physical object and that
it's finite and it has something
surrounding it it's an irrational
statement space is nothing that's the
problem and you know when you treat
space as nothing and nothing being that
which does not have shape okay then now
you can make sense of the universe and
so here's my first reply to that okay so
let's see if we can summarize it here if
the universe is a medium container thing
object then it has shape borders
boundaries surface by definition because
that's the definition of the word object
a thing is that which has shape okay the
proponent is required to identify the
entity medium thing object that
surrounds and capsule aids and gives
shape to the universe or to space draw
it I need a drawing I need for you to
put it on the board and identify what's
on the outside whether the number of
atoms particles planets stars galaxies
keeps going on forever
in other words incessant counting is a
separate matter with respect to the size
shape of the universe but it's easily
resolved if the word universe alludes to
a concept that universe is neither
finite nor infinite concepts have no
shape size or volume and therefore do
not enjoy the benefit of being qualified
or modified by adjectives if space is
not a physical object you cannot qualify
it with an adjective you cannot use
adjectives on what is not a noun for the
purposes of physics and only objects
qualify as nouns for the purposes of
physics
let's get that one straight okay and and
here's a finite universe ok yes here's a
pictorial thing of what I just talked
about here's the finite universe ok and
I need for you to identify the white
stuff if space is the black stuff or the
dark stuff there and all the stars in it
and you're saying that the universe is
finite I need to identify the white
stuff ok and if space is infinite as you
think it is because it's some kind of
infinite object of sorts whatever that
could possibly mean because if object is
that which has shape then there is no
such thing as an infinite finite an
infinite object ok so yeah we have a
contradiction that has to be resolved on
the board it's a conceptual issue we
don't go out there and start doing a
test and experiment to try to prove
something no this is a something you've
got to show here on earth ok and so yeah
the finite universe has a big problem
and the infinite space also has a
problem because infinite is an adjective
you can only apply it to things and
space is not a thing it's a concept
space means literally nothing and what
does nothing mean that which has no
shape ok so we have all this matter
floating around in that which has no
shape so that which has no shape you
cannot escape not even God can escape
that which has no shape there's no
border to cross ok there's no boundary
that he can say well what's on the other
side I'm gonna go over there aside from
the fact that if he goes over there he
probably uses
God becomes nothing because you know yes
thanks thank God to shape to space that
we have shape okay it provides the
contour to our bodies okay so what does
rational science propose well we
proposed a single loop a single closed
loop friend gang a single thread and
what is this it means the black stuff
that space what is that nothing
absolutely nothing what is nothing that
which doesn't have shape okay and the
single thread is all there is that's
what we are proposing we're saying all
the matter in the universe eventually
comes down to a single thread if we
could entangle every bit of matter this
is what we would end up with okay that's
our starting point really okay and then
what happens well what happens next is
the thread more so you can say it twice
around itself gazillions of times and it
forms atoms which later on form stars
and planets and whatever bigger stuff
the gases and that's what we end up with
and here's the construction of the atom
from this thread and see if I can get
bigger here okay here's the construction
um the thread it twines around itself
then it goes around forms the atom
that's a cross-section by the way so
that you see it in 2d and it was made by
mr. David Robinson he did a pretty good
job there of illustrating that and so
you have all these atoms right and so
which we end up is with this this
universe that looks more or less like
this it's all interconnected you can
think of those as just a bunch of atoms
you can also think of all those as every
galaxy in the universe either way it
doesn't matter because the concept is
the same and the notion the idea God you
know if he wants to exist you should
really be one of those atoms but you can
argue that God is outside the universe
outside that mesh gay
he's outside man
somewhere fine but God had better be in
space because space has no boundaries
and so God cannot escape space there is
no boundary to cross in space okay and
otherwise you got to make sense of space
before you talk about you know whether
God can leave you no space or not and
then the other issue is again and I I
don't care what God wants to hide
there better be a direct line distance
from my chest to his chest
I don't care where he can hide in the
twentieth dimension for all I care right
but there better be a straight line from
him to me
okay so God has no way of escaping my
distance I can catch God with my stick
just my straight stakeout point to God
anytime you know just tell me where he
is I should be able to point to good old
God okay another comment this was made
by another gentleman and I want to
address this as well and he said the
surface of a sphere is infinite we were
dealing with infinity is the surface of
a sphere is infinite no absolutely not
you can see that it's finite it just
ends there and the question is what do
you mean infinite you know what he's
saying really is this this if I can I've
Illustrated here okay and this is what
he really means you means you can run
around the sphere eternally forever okay
that's not infinity what that is is
incessant
and people confuse infinite with
incessant okay that's the problem it's a
question of language and you might say
you're doing semantics no no you got to
keep the words right this is not
infinite in the adjective incessantly
like in this case walking or running
incessantly around the sphere that's
something else you could also argue that
the sphere has infinite locations again
wrong usage of the word what you're
saying is that you're going to count
incessantly all the locations that any
object has
that matter between any two locations
you can find another one for sure yeah
it's just a question of getting a bigger
microscope and seeing you know between
two locations so counting locations is
that what you want to do because you're
not counting apples you're counting an
abstraction the the location where
something could be in County locations
yeah you can say that it's incessant
counting not infinite locations or
infinite points so we got to keep the
language straight the word infinite can
only be used in in the context of
objects there are no such thing as
infinite objects anywhere in the
universe okay and the the number of in
fact according to the rope model the
number of atoms I would like to use the
word atoms but we can say the amount of
matters is fixed constant it doesn't
change okay and that's a long story but
it doesn't change we always have the
same amount of matter because there's
only a single thread in the universe
closed loop thread and it doesn't grow
bigger it doesn't stretch it doesn't
it's not an elastic thread it's just the
same amount and forever forever and ever
from ever from ever and ever to ever and
ever okay both directions of time for
that matter okay and then there was
another comment here and it was the same
fellow I think and he says time equals
motion absolutely dot okay a clock is
not a boy running dying seconds is not
equal to meters per second but let's
let's put the correct definition so that
we can use them consistently the issue
here is again it's the issue whether
whether we have a rational definition or
an irrational one we're gonna use the
word time which we don't use in science
if that's used only in the religion of
mathematical physics we don't use the
word time in science we have no use for
it because time is essentially a
description and we have to explain not
describe and so here is a pictorial
representation of these two what is
motion motion involves one object moving
with respect to others whereas time
involves one object moving with respect
to another moving object we're comparing
the motions of two objects time requires
memory motion does not motion you move
by definition okay if you occupy two or
more locations you have moved in physics
for the purposes of physics time that's
not sufficient you need memory because
you need to compare the motion of the
Moon against the motion of something
else for example the earth okay when you
compare two motions now you have time
otherwise you don't have if you're just
comparing motion whatever the moon is
the only object in the universe is
moving you have no time yet because you
have nothing to engage it against the
only way you can do that is a motion of
something else then you have time you
need memory for time and that's what it
different what makes it different than
motion okay so no time and motion are
not the same thing not the same concepts
that not the same notions okay and it's
my second reply to that which is
essentially the definition okay and it
goes like this let me get myself back in
here okay so you have motion two or more
locations
that's what motion is so you move by
definition if if you meet that criteria
or criterion again two or more locations
you have moved according to physics time
no and I divide that in quantitative and
qualitative time qualitative time might
have some purpose in physics I don't
know before after yesterday today that's
qualitative time that's different in
quantitative time which is what the
mathematicians use which is a numerical
or quantitative quantitative relation
established between between two motions
one of which is a pre-established
standard you need to have first the
meter or the second or something before
you can talk about quantitative time so
time and motion are not synonymous first
quantitative time requires memory and it
requires two motion
okay so no for the purposes of at least
rational physics we do it first we have
no use for time but if we're glad you
find time that's that's what we've been
talking about all these hundreds of
years when we mentioned the word time
it's a comparison of two motions all
right okay with that I'm gonna see you
on Wednesday and I will continue with
mr. Aristotle in Euclid we're gonna get
back into the ball game we're gonna look
at infinity there's a little more
infinity to cover so please bear with me
hopefully this gentleman goes to see a
psychiatrist and maybe take some pills
or whatever we can withstand the history
lesson it's it's part of the job
description you need to know you need to
know a little bit of history if you want
to know how we ended up with black holes
Big Bang and other nonsense that we have
today you need to take it back all the
way to the Greeks no doubt about it you
need to lay the foundations of how we
got here and he was to skip all that
because yeah you know it's boring you
know and I don't have the mental
capacity to withstand all this stuff you
know and what can I say anyways we'll
see you on Wednesday and if yeah again
if you any of you can translate the book
please contact upset
kaká at hotmail.com okay we'll see you
on Wednesday
bye bye